it's now my privilege to sign the
Homeland Security Act Department of
Homeland Security will have nearly 170
000 employees
the threat of mass murder on our own
soil
will be met with a unified
effective response
so the Department of Homeland Security
DHS is celebrating its 20th birthday
which is a perfect opportunity to
rethink the whole concept of Homeland
Security and how to best provide it DHS
has grown into a monster child that is
massively expensive incredibly
ineffective and reliably destructive of
basic civil liberties it's time to
abolish it and replace it with fewer
smaller and more accountable agencies in
the wake of the 911 attacks President
George W bush called for the creation of
a new cabinet level department whose
primary mission is to protect the
American Homeland by pulling border
security emergency services and
immigration into a single streamlined
bureaucracy Bush promised that the new
Department would improve efficiency
without growing government instead we
got politically manipulated color-coded
Terror alerts that only made it easier
for late night comedians the threat
level is now
magenta
the DHS budget now stands at 82 billion
dollars or almost double its original
cost and inflation adjusted dollars are
there really twice as many threats to
the Homeland as there were when the
Embers at Ground Zero were still
smoldering and the global war on terror
was just ramping up in the early days of
the war on terror Washington was
obsessed with the idea that the 9 11
attacks happened because different
agencies notably the CIA FBI and NSA
didn't communicate with each other hence
the idea of a unified Homeland Security
structure but critics of DHS noted from
the start that it didn't actually reduce
bureaucracy or streamline much of
anything it just added a new layer of
red tape on top of existing agencies
while creating new ones such as the
Customs and Border Patrol and
Immigration and Customs Enforcement both
of which have become legendary for
callousness and root level failures
similarly the federal emerge management
agency FEMA has gone from catastrophic
failure in New Orleans all the way to
catastrophic failure in Puerto Rico
updating its long-standing stumblebum
reputation for the 21st century in a new
report FEMA admits failures occurred in
This Disaster Response to Hurricane
Maria a 2019 Inspector General report
called out DHS for failing to rein in
bad behavior ranging from padding
expense accounts to drinking on the job
to Illegal reprisals against sexual
harassment whistleblowers the report
concluded no one was really in charge of
organizing and inspecting reports of
employee misbehavior President Biden has
boasted that DHS has almost 260 thousand
employees yet its HR department told the
Inspector General it had limited
Staffing to perform these functions and
staff do not believe they are
responsible for managing the allegation
process perhaps worst of all DHS is a
determined foe of civil liberties as the
Asa value documents in a new study of
the department DHS routinely undermines
our ability to speak and move freely
about the very country it's supposed to
be protected for instance since
immigration enforcement became part of a
national security agenda ice agents
encourage local police to stop arrest
and bring low-level charges against
people who look like immigrants with the
actual aim of helping ice Deport them
looking like an immigrant isn't against
the law and it shouldn't be a pretext
for a police stop and when we talk about
DHS of course we have to talk about the
Transportation Security Administration
TSA
brilliant TSA which you might refer to
as thousands standing around the
testicle squeezing agency or any number
of different euphemisms despite very
occasional positive headlines the TSA
rightly looms large in the public
imagination as a make work program gone
horribly wrong famous for forcing
mothers to drink their around breast
milk scaring children and pantsing the
elderly the TSA reportedly spends as
much as 667 billion dollars per life
saved on its 10th anniversary two
Conservative Republican members of
Congress even denounced the TSA saying
the degraded security theater it imposed
on Travelers did not improve on the
safety protocols that were in place
before 9 11. dhs's mission is simply too
fast to accomplish having been tasked to
do so many different things from
processing immigration checks to
responding to natural disasters to
checking passengers on every flight in
America to stopping terrorism it ends up
doing all of them poorly it would be
better to break those functions up into
smaller agencies that are directly
accountable to departments that existed
prior to 9 11. as Richard A Clark a
30-year veteran of security positions in
the defense department state department
and white house has suggested it makes
sense to create a smaller group tightly
focused on terroristic threats that
would work directly with the FBI in the
office of National Intelligence
preserving the status quo he writes will
only perpetuate the mistakes made in the
Panic trauma that followed 911 and
doomed these important missions to
continued mishandling and lack of
success as it celebrates its 20th
birthday it's time to blow out the
candles on DHS